welcome everyone to floor gang sealing
gang I don't even need to say it at this
point
just stop another thing that's cringe is
strange videos today we're gonna look at
the strangest videos online
there's strangest videos oh I have no
idea what to expect
cyber sent me this Twitter I don't do
Twitter but we should watch what a
classic tick-tock how do they do that
that's a movie magic right there exact
same thing alright I mean that's funny
I left twice now do those fruit blue be
packing now goddamn never eats fruit
straight out of the box that's very
dangerous these are so unexpected I
don't know what to believe anymore
Oh God I don't know if I should be
laughing what is happening I can't watch
this I can't out that's is that a banked
I better not be it back
Oh what it's a flying lemur oh they
actually look cute because there's a
hook in its mouth from the people trying
to hunt it
that's awful screw you people you suck
people it's wrong with you don't do that
that's awful
I saw this and I'm like that's not
really good I've seen this and I looked
over here and I was like well [ __ ]
that's not good either yeah woman drive
car woman not good driving women bad I
said it someone had to say it you like
Wendy's Wendy's nut smack you in the
face perfectly cut beautiful thank you
another laugh
[Music]
hell yeah as a sexy beast that's a sexy
what's gonna come out oh god it's so
funny because when I used to do horror
games everyone would accuse me if I get
scared easily I can't it's a natural
reaction because I'm so much
testosterone that anything that comes at
me I meet with that which is a tactic
defense tactic night sweetie daddy yes
dear
please help me check on that for my
students I don't like this go for the
record if my child this is I'll be like
nah you check you check you check the
floor you should be sleeping on the
floor right this is plagiarized I mean I
guess you can't really complain it's a
cool I think it was a red short story or
something like that they try to write a
yeah I think that's where I heard it at
least so maybe they stole it for
somewhere but it's a that's a great I
feel like it worked better in written
form almost shut the hell up
go kill yourself go sit in the middle of
the road let a car run oh okay I don't
know what dr. Phil is up to I heard he
make tic TOCs videos now him I don't
know what to say dr. Phil sign I don't
know what to say that's not good advice
[Music]
second time then the commentary made
that that was beautiful goddamn I'm
actually having fun how about that here
it is again the legend it's the same
claim don't waste my time
alright unimpressed next alright the
music is doing this nothing else so I'm
just gonna pop out I'm ready
all right full testosterone I will not
react well I can't damn it I can't see
anything what what ok we will analyze
the footage yeah got it
it makes me scared look I get goose
bumps I don't know what it is and my
imagination is scarier than the video my
mind is the scariest place if you took
two I think the mexic that those neck
rolls is the scariest part of this Jesus
Christ so you look at that his hand ok
nevermind what what do you say god it
annoys me cuz I know everyone is calming
be like ok alright look at the baby stop
posting memes canards oh ok that was a
person that went cool all right what do
we got we got some whipped cream in a
glass this is great so unexpected I love
it it's like I don't know how to react
and like support the fact that it's
mixed with funny ones makes it so much
better because I don't know what's to
come it really catches the off guard
and then there's those and I know that's
all it is
well it's a good thing this in the Nile
a felix casaya would be concealing gang
right there number 15
[Music]
me and the boys practicing our fortnight
dance going to fortnight school go in a
fortnight training camp before we're
sending out to wake up in the morning
feeling like it's a good life life is
good you wake up and you feel good oh no
what does this mean what did you do to
these people maybe because people that
he helped huh have you ever thought of
that stop looking at so cynically world
badly I saw this yeah oh that's
confusing what am I supposed to say
about this huh what am I supposed to do
oh that was his harsh that was his harsh
[Music]
sorry I did not catch that that was Fred
Flintstone
professor gadget and combined will make
[Music]
that's genius this is genius well then a
pause
Pam you get a tambourine well then come
on your shoes raggedy that's why your
mama did damn I didn't realize I knowing
orange was so epic dude time to re-watch
[Laughter]
why is that funny
god bless god bless you sir
[Music]
this should have cured the soundtrack
for hereditary a few of you will know
what I mean that's it that's it five
five thousand retweets really Wow okay
alright the bar is high now it's gonna
be tough to be this is Casey nice-size
newest video going through New York
absolutely crazy
sponsored by Samsung and everyone
laughed they just spread joy they they
went on a porta potty and they handed
out iPods and everyone laughed it was
amazing that's impressive though to be
real ceiling gang though cringe sorry I
was gonna smash like subscribe but nah
oh no oh no oh no all right here we go
I love my girlfriend and I'm totally
fine with dudes jacking off to pictures
of her on the Internet
doesn't affect me one where to do what
okay oh heck yeah
[Music]
we've spotted an alligator that seems to
be in trouble so there's only one seems
to be in trouble
only one is that got a dog that jumps in
no there's only one thing to do
strangle him choke hold him I don't know
how to do a choke hold
I know how to do it on an alligator no
shoes nothing all right
damn that's impressive no one's ever
done before what the hell so agrees up
the pole or something what's happening
no Felix it's just women they play like
that okay all right got it got it
women bad got it understand rememeber
right lads a litigator
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I wish they kept longer
[Applause]
oh my god this could have been edited so
much better if they kept this longer and
then for the second screen they swish -
right am I the only team that have all
sorts of fun game how do you know there
was a robber so a cell rotavirus and
make protein that have also I mean I
don't I can't tell you I couldn't tell
you sorry
do I look sexy yeah Thank You papi do I
look sexy yeah Thank You papi I'm so
confused
but amuse at the same time I like it no
minions huh god damn that's strong
I just all right I dig it
surprises necklace didn't get worried
tweet that's hilarious
- or them
you never know you never know dude guys
there's more than enough for all of us
this is it this is it cheap that makes
me laugh literally it's genius
you don't understand mom it's genius
comedy it's ironic and obscure cringe
punchline shut the flip up what K draw
basis I need to watch it or Indian drama
for that matter I love it
beautiful okay guys time to end video if
you enjoyed gently hit the like button
subscribe if your tambourine gang
subscriber e for floor again and see you
tomorrow subscribe and much okay like in
a world where science knows
dreams travel to land where no tuber has
been and explore never-before-seen
landscapes encounter beings that are
extinct lead Mayan actors as esters who
collect ancient items rediscover your
favorite scientifically accurate dinos
what will you create
you